Tim Roth has played some Stellar roles
with many of them being antagonists in
movies like Pulp Fiction Selma and the
hateful eight obviously with all that
under his belt it's clear that he'd be
one of the first choices for Severus
Snape Tim was super interested in the
role and almost signed up for it then
and there but unfortunately he was also
interested in Tim Burton's Planet of the
Apes remake he even tried to make both
roles work and create some super intense
work schedule ultimately though he just
didn't have enough time in the day and
ended up filming the Planet of the Apes
remake and passing on defense against
the dark arts